[Applause]
it's like the blue collar ivy like we
have a hotel school
and we have a really good architecture
program so you go to cornell
you you you study architecture yes okay
you start a tech business start an
architecture company and then a tech
company
okay so you start the architecture
company first yes tech company yeah you
go back to school
no i did my undergrad and grad all at
one time
you [ __ ] so basically i didn't
start college till i was 21 i was a 21
year old college freshman oh
neither one of my parents went to
college they never said take the sats i
had no idea whether or not i'd be good
at school
yeah so i ended up going to community
college yeah and
i promise you he's asian i promise you
yeah but i'm also half white so you know
yeah yeah and that is a dominant [ __ ]
gene when it comes to your academics
yes uh so i took the sats when i was
like 20 hilarious did really well on
them
didn't know i had need to have a
calculator uh and
the one of my teachers at community
college was like you kind of go wherever
you want and that's why i was like all
right
but it actually ended up being kind of a
blessing to get a late start because
while everyone else is throwing up in
their first year of college and figuring
out how to like drink and live on their
own i don't really
were interested i was already working
yeah like a sort of adult
and so i was like oh college is
expensive and i was paying for it yeah
like i'm gonna
the more credits i take per semester the
more you can get the less i spend on
housing and those kind of things yeah
yeah yeah
and i'm like i don't need to [ __ ] around
and figure out how to join a fraternity
and all that kind of stuff yeah
um so i was just like i'm gonna get my
money's worth out of this
yeah um so blasted right through college
really fell in love with
with design and then actually stayed on
and became part of the faculty so i
didn't start college until i was 21 but
i was a ivy league
i guess not a professor but a visiting
lecturer same thing basically
you're just one teaching and leading and
creating the classes by the time i was
right then i started a sustainable
architecture firm zero energy design we
leveraged a bunch of new technology and
3d uh modeling to kind of get ahead
and then i thought okay i'm pretty
clever and in like 2006 you could kind
of
raise money for a tech startup pretty
easy it's like there's been these booms
yeah yeah
and i'm like all right i have this idea
i'm gonna make architecture free because
that's what everybody's doing with the
internet
yeah uh as they're taking something that
was paid made it free
blow up and things yeah so it worked i
went out and i gave a powerpoint
presentation
we won this all ivy league sort of
business plan competition
and we got an investment of over a
million dollars i was like wait
you can do a powerpoint and people give
you a million dollars like
and i thought i was so [ __ ] smart
yeah i was just like cocky i was just
like oh you know i just changed the way
i talked i started using all these like
tech bro jargons because because i was
experimenting in this place
i got rewarded for those experiments and
it reinforced this kind of like
arrogant kind of tech douchey behavior
yeah
then 2008 happens and our business model
was
to was to uh sell advertising in the
construction industry yeah yeah what
happened to construction budgets
what happened to advertising they went
to less than nothing
and not only that the fund that was
investing in us because we were a
sustainability
forward business yeah they were invested
in all the u.s solar and sustainability
companies
which all evaporated the fund went under
we were owed another
uh half of the money of the million that
we were promised
but the fund went under so they couldn't
give us the rest of the money we had to
lay off people
and it was a great lesson because what i
learned was
i'm not as smart as i think i was right
like or where success isn't an indicator
of how smart you are
yeah it's yeah yeah it's partially that
yeah
uh and my ideas weren't bad but they
also weren't as great as the results
too yeah and i was like okay this is
this is humbling
yeah um but fundamentally what i learned
is that the
the idea that i had which was to i loved
architecture i loved designing things
but when you have to monetize design as
a service that means you're only making
it
available to people that can pay for
custom services
and so the more successful i got as an
architect designing sustainable houses
the richer my clients got
so i was designing like five to ten
million dollars sustainable homes
congratulations to those really rich
people that have a second or third home
that uses less carbon
yeah doing absolutely [ __ ] nothing
for the environment at the same time i'm
winning environmental rewards and that
hypocrisy
drove me [ __ ] crazy because it's like
driving a hydrogen-powered
escalade and being like yeah i'm not
even flexing with these spinners but
like
my fuel source is actually really clean
and meanwhile you have [ __ ] eight gas
powered cars in your garage as well
right it's complete [ __ ] but at the
same time
you kind of you're not doing that to be
a fraud you're doing that because you're
kind of just like pushed into things
you're like oh i care about
sustainability
these are the people paying to me and
then you try to justify what you're
being forced into
yeah and that's why when people call
people frauds i'm always like
are they frauds or are they just like
victims of like the pressures that
they're kind of pushed into
now they're fraudulent if they oversell
their actual good that they're doing
but they're not necessarily terrible
people for making compromised choices as
we all have to
you don't have to be terrible to be a
frog no i don't think all frauds are
terrible but i think
the uh you can be for you can be a fraud
as long as you're aware of what you're
doing yeah
so the thing i learned self-awareness
that makes you a fraud yes the thing i
learned with the tech company that i end
up is what i sort of
the the thing that i pulled from that
failure was that
i could design uh i could give away my
design ideas for free i didn't have to
charge people
okay so if i produce design as media
content and then monetize it through
marketing
i could not i didn't have to charge
people to access my ideas and that was
really fun that felt like it opened up
this kind of it
unlocked this whole way of reaching
people is that now i can design
affordable things was before i had to
only design expensive things
so yeah and i actually got i think like
i always thought gmail was such an
impressive thing i know like
multi-millionaires that uses gmail i
know people like mark that use gmail
yeah uh
like it's like the one product is great
for rich people and it's great for
everyone else it's in and out
so it's like can i do that with like
design yeah so i started making
youtube videos yeah and uh they sort of
took off
and i started by building like little
things like coffee tables
and just like fun diy projects that
would look nicer than
store-bought furniture and be way
cheaper yeah and then slowly scale that
all the way up to bigger and bigger
projects because now we're building
spiral staircases with robots we're
still building the cheap and easy stuff
we're building shipping container houses
we're recycling windmill blades
yeah and i want to get to that i said
but but with the same idea right
is you're going to give away the
architecture you're going to give away
the design and then you'll monetize the
advertising on giving that away
you're telling people how to make these
things you're not saying i want you to
buy the chair from me you're saying this
is how you make the chair yourself
and i'm going to do an advertisement
with home depot and get all my material
with home depot like
to me you like broke the advertisement
when we first sat down like
you shattered the mold you're like it
was just such a great idea to basically
get the people who provide the materials
that you're gonna use for the video to
pay you
instead of the consumer right and it
actually benefits
the home depot whoever else is providing
it because
those people that want to make your
chair are going to have to go to home
depot you know where you get like a new
sponsor they're always like here's the
call to action
yeah yeah yeah i made it right
for you and then the whole video is the
call to action and then you said this to
me
uh this is what i thought was brilliant
you said that the was it i
uh home and garden network or one of
these like hdtv yeah
hetv home depot might spend half a
million dollars
on a tv advertisement on a show on home
and garden tv that costs 80 000.
the show itself costs 80 000 to make
right so if you tell home depot yo
hit me off with i don't know what the
[ __ ] you get we're just gonna put our
trade number out there
hey give me 50 000 right i'll give you
the show the show the advertisement i'll
give you the whole thing
and then you use facebook whatever the
[ __ ] you want to put those ads out there
in the world yeah
they saved 450 000 and got to target the
exact people that you want
with an influencer so that's what we did
with the shipping container house
[ __ ] bro
is we originally pitched it to netflix
oh sorry just so so then you went from
making these
you're making these small projects you
start building up right you do
you call it furniture then you start
going into uh
bigger sort of home improvement uh home
remodeling like remodeling a whole
bathroom
building out an entire kitchen and then
from there we started using robots and
3d printers
and when do you get into the container
that was in 2018.
the container thing is so brilliant
because i think like for tax reasons
yeah there's some tax advantages for the
depreciation thing it's complex but if
you have a lot of passive income
look into like industrial assets and
buying them
and talk to a tax attorney about how you
can use it to offset your passive income
anyway yeah but i was interested in that
because
when when i look for content ideas i
look at one what's popular you can look
for what's popular by what people are
searching for but that's just
one end of the economic spectrum yeah
supply is the other
aspect of on the other side of the coin
of demand yeah
so i'll look for things like oh there's
a lot of people searching for shipping
container
housing content like could these be
affordable housing could this be a
solution for my little tiny house cabin
that i want
and there's and there wasn't a lot of
supply showing good information it's
like a few guys in australia that like
built them with charming accents
consider
consider this creators if you're a
creator and you're watching like
if you're making the same type of
content that a thousand other creators
are making
that's a lot of competition right but if
there's a lot of desire which is what
ben was saying
there's a lot of desire for a certain
type of content
and not a lot of people making it right
that's how you get to the top of the
internet
there's proportionately more vegans in
vegan restaurants
vegan restaurants are a better
investment even if veganism isn't more
popular than conventional eating
and so that's what we saw was sort of
the shipping container house thing so
we pitched it to netflix and amazon
being like hey we want to do like this
whole series pitch it to hgtv
the hgtv was the most interested and
they said well
you'd have to build a house an episode
and we're like no no people want to know
the details they want to how do you get
building permits how do you do septic
when you flush a toilet where does it go
how do you insulate it and you can't
tell that in one episode
so we stuck to our guns and we said
we'll do it on youtube we got home depot
to sort of underwrite it provide all the
materials for it so we built an entire
shipping container house
all out of stuff from home depot we
built the whole thing for
under 200 000 in california expensive
place to build yeah showed every step of
the process
and then we rented it on airbnb for like
six to seven thousand dollars a month
and ended up selling it for 385 000.
amazing and that's what's really fun is
that we can tell you the numbers
too we don't have to like be like oh
yeah it's all smoke and mirrors we'll
show you the receipts like
it's it's much more fun and interesting
that way and
series blows up yeah we did so the
average hdtv show i think does about 800
000 views per episode yeah we did about
2 million views per episode and we
launched it on a new channel
yeah that's right you had no follow-up
zero subscribers went from zero to like
370 subscribers and averaged about two
million views in episodes
yeah and that was where we're sort of
like and that's why i still think like
youtube is such an interesting platform
it is just great you don't have to wait
for the permission
like we're in talks now again with the
platform so you still always got to
entertain your options
but it still comes down to you're going
to have to spend six months of back and
forth
negotiating figuring it out detailing it
but now they're on your timeline yeah
and now they know
that you don't need to go with them
right because you can create it yourself
and you can monetize yourself and you
have the proof you can
start an entirely new channel and you
have confidence that you can build it up
right it's a completely different game
right now so if you want to take the bag
from them by all means take the bag and
there is value to being validated
by them but you don't have to wait for
them you can constantly strengthen
and this is what i always build and when
they're ready to take the shot
never stop moving yeah even as you're
waiting for them to sort of come around
exactly like just constantly reinforce
and strengthen your position
yeah so i always like that when like
ebay first happened ebay is like so
early internet
yeah i saw this story of this guy they
started with like a paper clip and then
he traded it
like a cigarette lighter and created a
cigarette lighter for like a stapler
all the way up to a car and then to a
house yeah you can do the same thing
like that with your career and content
yeah is you can start with what you can
do right in front of you make some
content get a little audience
do a little bit of a bigger project yeah
keep growing and trickle it up
yeah and it's funny in like six years we
went from making
coffee tables to whole houses and now
we're like recycling
30 foot long windmill blades and
building hotels
you